tahar est ce que les producteurs et les
metteurs en scène vous parle sur un
autre temps depuis que votre frère
ministre de la culture je ne parle plus
je sais si c'est non non non non il me
parle plus en fait c'est cela qui est
curieux c'est que je pense que tout le
monde avec une pudeur de cette situation
oui c'est d'ailleurs plutôt agréable de
savoir que tous les mois qui suit
impudique de vous en parler des as
dragon smaug style mais autrement les
autres find ignorait que votre frère et
leurs autorités de tutelle à dire la
situation délicate de mon frère et mon
ministre de tutelle et mokaddem avocats
d'els donc avec la perspective de
possibilités de paires de claques simone
est ce que vous préférez le chômage à un
mauvais film bat jusqu'à présent oui
c'est peut-être changé avec plage parce
que des fois d'avenir sont conformes
jusqu'à présent je préfère être soulagée
de savoir si le chômage que pratiquent
activement que 20h30 pratiquement depuis
que mon frère le milieu de la culture
je ne vois pas le machiavélisme mr
freche d'une passe il en soit ainsi
sinon ça sera de la ségrégation aux
pêcheurs ainsi l'enjeu est il exact que
vous soyez monarchiste oui c'est exact
plus toujours parce que c'est la
position de mon père je monarchie c'est
un mot qui peut tromperie c'est mon père
m'a élevé dans l'idée que
pour qu'il soit vraisemblable et
crédible à pouvoir de la durée et être
transmis sans que les gens se battent
pour l'obtenir c'est plutôt contre la
foire d'empoigné
enfin transmis éventuellement à des
incompétents comme c'est le cas
avez-vous appris beaucoup de choses en
habitants durant un an chez coluche
ouais bon avec beaucoup de choses de
plus que sa plus que ça si garder sa
maison pas un an et puis ensuite vécu
avec lui ses points et fabrice la
dernière phrase que j'ai entendu une
michelle trois mois zacharias devant
nous et sa cascade c'est 18 soit coluche
en plus fin à ce stage à l'est et à ben
c'est pas mon fort oui il va bien